good evening to you everyone tiff
florento here in the 8 news now weather
center and as you probably read the
headline there uh we want to explain and
break down everything that's going to go
on
with this nor'easter this bomb cyclone
that is already starting to batter uh
the east coast the reason why it's
important is because this is one of the
biggest storms for them for in years
and of course could be the biggest storm
uh of the year for sure and it's going
to impact us in a certain way too our
weather's fantastic you're going to see
that at 11. the reason i'm doing this is
because i want to dedicate my 11 o'clock
weather strictly to you strictly to 8
news now or to to las vegas weather on 8
news now because we want to know the
weekend recreation forecast we want to
know how the temperatures are going to
be how the sky is going to be and how
the winds are so i want to dedicate all
that to you
for las vegas and southern nevada and
dedicate the nor'easter and the east
coast weather to uh facebook here on
facebook and online so uh you can share
that with all your friends first i want
to
turn this camera around and kind of
explain to you because i've had to cover
four of these all right
these nor'easters these coastal storms
when i worked in philly you guys
remember when i left briefly well i had
to cover four nor'easter's in one year
first i want to begin with this those of
you that are from the east coast you
know what i'm talking about give us let
me know if you're from the east coast
lisa are you from the east coast i can't
remember if you just said that you're
from there or not you guys all know what
this is like if you lived along the east
coast so all these watches and warnings
and alerts in effect right now
uh go from the carolinas all the way up
to maine all right so as we close in
these white areas are blizzard warnings
okay we're talking strong winds whipping
around snow
and that goes all the way from maine
all the way through hartford
oh man new york
long island look at this all the way
down to uh delaware
and through atlantic city philadelphia
wow so we also have winter storm
warnings which you see in purple
coastal warnings too because we could
also have some flooding as well along
the coast so a lot going on here
next we're going to go to the satellite
and radar linda from the east coast you
know i'm talking about i had a friend
that just moved there
uh scott probably going to join in
because
he's just moved to atlantic city from
las vegas
i know he loves it out there but scott
we we just told him to hunker down so
right now already seeing some of the
snow increase these areas where you see
the darker shades of
blue it's where we're getting some
heavier snow coming down right now and
as you can see that coastal low uh
mixing in with that cold arctic air
changing it over snow up along the coast
the delmarva all the way up the i-95
corridor tri-state area new york already
getting hit philly getting some snow
already all right so is atlantic city
for sure uh tom's river
long island moving up to providence all
right not quite up in maine just yet but
this is friday night
and it will continue to move its way up
now let's get to our future cast and
show you what to expect real quick
though okay what we mean by a bomb
cyclone
is the fact that it has a rapid
intensification all right the center of
the storm okay the the pressure uh it
rapidly intensifies and that creates a
very very strong wind along with the two
so here's what we're going to see for
those of you joining us okay so this low
will continue to move up along the coast
just to note the further it is outshore
the more snow you're going to get all
right the more closer it is or even on
shore the more you tend to get stronger
winds but this is still going to produce
very strong winds so right now when you
see these little
ice what we call them isobars the closer
they get that tells us how strong the
winds are look how close these are
together compared to out here so this is
going to whip around such strong winds
this could provide coastal flooding as
it pushes the water up along the
coastline there the blue areas indicate
where we're getting some heavy rain or
heavy snow and that's a lot of dark blue
coming up along the coast remember
delaware
okay
new jersey
uh pennsylvania philly new york
long island and then we're looking at
boston and nantucket new england these
areas there it's going to go up along
the coast there whipping around those
very strong winds with gusts possibly up
to 50 miles per hour in spots maybe even
more and it will continue up along the
coast of over towards maine okay so
we're talking a lot of snow a lot of
strong winds there are blizzard warnings
for a reason because visibility will
reduce to less than a quarter of a mile
it'll almost be wide out in fact a lot
of the governors even the boston
governor has talked about the fact that
people should just stay in and not even
go out at all snow totals when it's all
over and done with look at this we're
looking at anywhere in boston
and bangor maine possibly up to two feet
of snow
two feet okay when i worked in
philadelphia i've had to cover four of
these and two of those give us a foot of
snow and it was bad like you could even
you couldn't go anywhere so these guys
are looking at two feet of snow when
this is over and done with when we're
talking about sunday to monday so they
got a lot going up against them and the
reason why this could impact us guys is
the fact that anybody flying out you
could have a ripple effect as far as
cancellations go and delayed flights so
keep that in mind if you're going to the
east coast this is probably not a good
time again
they're all out there getting ready for
this
they all know about hitting um
when when i was out there everyone would
go hit all the grocery stores and get
all the milk and eggs and hunker down
and that's what my friend scott is doing
that's what i'm sure a lot of your
relatives are doing and those of you
that are from the east coast
congratulations you're in great weather
here in las vegas coming up at 11
o'clock i'm going to explain exactly
what to expect this weekend for
recreation from the mountain to the lake
to maybe las vegas to the local parks
we'll talk about winds we'll talk about
what to expect as far as temperatures go
and what to expect next week as we head
into their first week of february thank
you guys for watching please share this
with your friends especially anybody
that might be heading the east coast or
with your uh your east coast relatives
out there so have a great night guys and
we will see you on 8 news now at 11.